うわぁぁぁぁう
うぉい
ぼいぼいぼい
おぼいおぼいおぼ
あの、ちょっと愚痴っていいですか
大学を卒業してから非常に東京に行くことが多い
一週間のうちで毎週三日間か四日間はほぼ東京にいるんで、
東京に行ってる間の動画の分も撮ってから
東京に行っている間の動画も撮ってから東京に行くんですよ
東京に行くんですよ
で、そういうのが３日間も４日間も続くと
そういうのが3日間も4日間も続くとー
もっ…　時間がないんすよ
もう、じ…
時間がないんすよ
全然時間がない…けどもさ、
そのさぁ、動画撮るのも
寝る時間がないけど動画撮るのも楽しいしさー
楽しいからさぁ、全然苦じゃないんですけど
辛くないのに寝る時間が
あぁ、ないなぁみたいな感じで
徹夜で東京行っちゃうからさぁ
なんかもう、そろそろ…
まじで
体調がおかしくなりそうだなと思ってます
はじめしゃちょーです！
誰か助けてください…
まぁいいんですよ、全然いいです
ただ、そろそろね、ちょっと
今のままの生活だと本当に
体がおかしくなりそうなんで
何かしらちょっと手は打とうと思っております
東京には…
行きたくありません！
まぁでも、楽しいんで
なんとかやってるんですけども
まぁ純粋に
あぁ…今日も寝れねぇな
みたいな日が続いております
もう、そろそろなんかね
一人だと限界なのかなと思ってきちゃって
エンディング動画も見れないし
そのエンディング動画も頑張って
時間見つけてちまちま見てるんで
すみません…もう少々お待ちください
ほんとに…時間がないんです…
スプラトゥーンやりたい
パッパパッパパラララ〜
ちょっともうね酔いの勢いで
今日は撮っちゃうよ
今回はちょっと、食べ物を使った
とあることをやってみようと思います
ゔぉ
まずはこちら
そしてこちら
PON!
マヨネーズと梅干しを一緒に食べると
あら不思議
調べよう
そうだった、あれだあったあった、そうだった
えっとですね
あっ、バキッ
俺は、ネットで見つけてしまった
マヨネーズと梅干し
この二つを混ぜると
なんと、なぁんとですね
ホットドッグの味になるらしいです
いやぁ…すげぇよ…
マヨネーズと、梅干しを
混ぜるだけで、ホットドッグになるなんて
いやすごいっすよだって、マヨネーズはまぁ別として
梅干しは健康にいいじゃないですか
梅干しを食べて
ジャンクフードのホットドッグの味を感じられる
まさに、アンビリーバボーだと思いませんか？
そこのあなた
090-ピーーーーー(規制音)
やべ、電話番号、言っちゃった
ちょ、落ち着こう一回
ね、はじめん
ではでは、早速やってみましょう
開いた
ゔえ
なんか僕、梅干しそんなに好きじゃないんですよ
まず、梅干しちょっと一つ食べてみましょう
じゃ、マヨネーズ入れます
あ、入りましたね
ホットドッグだ…
え…
ホットドッグだ！
待って、衝撃的すぎて酔いが覚めてきたわ
え、ホットドッグっすよ…なんでだろう？
ホットドッグ味って言われて、多分みなさん
パッとこないと思うんですけど
あの、これやってみたらわかります
もう口の中で、はっ
ピーヤって頭ん中来るんで
こんなにがっつりきますかってぐらい
なんか、ホットドッグって感じがします
ちょっともう一回いってみます
ちょっと
う〜ん、うんうん
ホットドッグだこれは
まじでホットドッグの味がします
というわけで、あのですねちょっと
あんまり最近、近況報告みたいなことが
できてなかったんですけども
昔はね、なんか動画の中で
ちまちま近況報告をしてたんですけども
最近あまり出来てなかったなと思いまして
なかなか大学生の時とは違う
忙しさとプレッシャーがある中
日々ちょっと、頑張っておりますので
なんとか、ここを乗り越えて
しっかりと着実に
やらなきゃいけないことをこなしていって
好きな動画を撮れたらなと思っております
頑張ろう
はじめ頑張れ、みんながついてる
ただ寝る時間は欲しい
寝る時間は欲しいけど頑張ります
今日も朝から東京だけど
じゃあな！
あ、あの、美味しいからまじでやってみてね